[Music]
bianca thank you so much for joining us
today
thank you for inviting me it's really a
pleasure to be here
today with you your work is all related
to
justice why is justice so important to
you well
i was born in nicaragua and uh a
dictatorship the dictatorship of this
monster that was
involved for 39 years and i watch
um the
the way the oppression
of the people of nicaragua throughout my
childhood and adolescence
and as well as so nicaragua and i saw
justice and injustice to the prisoner of
my mother's eyes
and uh my mother was a very very
political and very committed
uh woman and uh and i also saw
her being discriminated because of her
gender because she had to work
and because she was a woman and because
she was divorced
and so through my mother as well i
learned
um what it was how a
a society could really repress and
discriminate a woman
and and i think that by watching
what the dictatorship and the brutal
uh samoans that detective she did to the
citizens of nicaragua
and by watching how my mother was
discriminated uh
made me feel that i needed to commit my
life
to defending women to defending um
those who are persecuted and uh and to
fight for democracy for the rule of law
and for the right
women and girls so i think that is
is very simple and and a lot of people
uh don't seem to understand really they
think that
um that they don't see the connection
between
human rights uh climate change justice
um the environment all of it is
connected
is is is a we have to see it through
through a prisma of one it's a one
uh especially now i think with the
coronavirus we realized
uh really how important it is that we
look at the bigger picture
not that we try to compartmentalize
and to think that uh the rights of women
or that the environment of that justice
um that those are not part of justice
those are
all part of justice and i think that is
the reason why
my foundation um that may seem to some
people
uh that has engaged and that campaigns
for different
issues uh i always come back to
uh the the fact that they are all
connected to
that we must fight for justice
i think it would be wrong to talk about
justice today without mentioning
ruth bader ginsburg because we all woke
up to
to the news that the supreme court
justice died
um how did you feel hearing that because
she was obviously such a huge advocate
for women's rights like you are
are you are you concerned about the
supreme court going forward
you know i i was i was doing my hair and
getting ready when i learned about that
and and i put a twitter in a hurry to
say
how deeply saddened i am because she was
a true champion of justice
uh she is one of the most extraordinary
women
and the idea that we lose her at this
moment in time
when it's so critical and it is so
critical of who will be
the president in the united states we
already
had justice um from the supreme court
that were nominated by
by donald trump and and we know uh that
it was a tremendous
controversy about who he elected and and
judges at
all level uh so i am so
saddened uh to think that we have lost
her
on that who will replace it uh she is
irreplaceable
it will be very difficult to have a
a justice supreme court justice
uh like her
again i hope that it exists but
i i put her together with um
with my great heroes you know great
woman here
um i'm deeply sad and deeply sorry
yes i completely agree she's definitely
irreplaceable
um on the topic of justice there are
obviously a lot of different ways to
fight for justice and despite being an
environmental campaigner yourself
you're recently quite vocal about some
of the acts of
extinction rebellion particularly their
choice to block
newspaper printing sites can you tell me
why you felt so passionately
about that i agree with many of the
issues
that they are struggling for uh perhaps
um i want to be very clear why
i felt that perhaps they made a mistake
about
trying to put an obstacle to the release
of the
uh the printing of the newspaper uh i
i'm coming from from nicaragua from a
country
where freedom of the press and freedom
of
speech is at stake where
at the moment you have uh canal 12
that has been embargo that you have many
of the important newspapers in nicaragua
like
um you know carlos fernando tomorrow
and and confidential a hundred percent
news in nicaragua that have been closed
journalists that have been killed
journalists that have been put in jail
uh so i think
and it's what i said really the the
headlines for me was that
freedom of the press is sacrosanct in no
way of course i support
what the government is saying that they
will go after them and that they are
um and that they committing crime not at
all
i mean you know people can make a
mistake i was only speaking
from my perspective but what their
objective eyes
and their concerns about uh that the
environment
is an an existential threat i totally
agree
because i think that governments have
failed us
governments throughout the world
including the government in the uk
um in in not taking the right measures
and not really preventing catastrophic
climate change
i think that we have seen in the last
few months
uh beside the pandemic you know the the
melting of the ice
we are seeing what is happening today um
all over the world and what will and and
this devastating fires
in the us in in in brazil
and in many other countries that the
media are not focusing
yes we must and we need to take
radical actions uh to um
to get the attention of the media to get
the attention of government
and to get them to adopt the right
measures to prevent
uh catastrophic climate change but i
feel
very strongly that we must be very
careful
when we take measures that put
in danger freedom of the press even if
the press
as they are right to say is by us
sometimes
and is not telling us what we need to
know about the environment
about brexit about uh covet 19
uh which is the case in this country but
despite that
uh we need to have freedom of the press
and freedom
you said that we do need radical action
in some
circumstances of course extinction
rebellion's whole philosophy
is about civil disobedience to push
their agenda
do you think breaking the law is
necessary to get the climate crisis
taken seriously civil disobedience
is an important um aspect
of of campaigning
to get the uh
the attention of governments and to let
governments know
that um that what they their policies
are wrong
for example uh whether we're talking uh
with regards to the environment or black
lives matter
or indigenous people's lives matter
is important and sometimes we need to
take
radical measures for them to pay
attention
and uh obviously i will never
support anything that is violent i will
always believe
in peaceful uh in in peaceful objection
i will always believe in in peaceful uh
movements
like the movement in nicaragua the
movements we have seen in other parts of
the world in india
um i am a great fan of gandhi and
believe
uh and believe the in the power of a
peaceful movement
of peaceful resistance um
yes very interesting on the topic of
kind of law breaking
i wanted to speak a bit about our
government at the moment there have been
widespread concerns that the british
government is attempting to break
international law to push its brexit
plans
what do you make of our government
i think it's appalling i think that we
have heard
um voices of great jurist
of great important um politicians
you know that most of the former prime
minister
have come out and condemned the actions
of
boris johnson i think he's completely
wrong
the uk is supposed to stand for the rule
of law
we are losing uh credibility we are
losing respect throughout the world
and this will not end well i mean
i of course have been very vocal against
brexit
i think that um that brexit is
that how they are managing uh brexit
and the negotiation just like how they
are managing
um covered 19 is being
shambolic to say the least so
i am very concerned to continue watching
this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas